start well anyway so I'm going to read
it off there just say hi I'm AR
schwartzer that's supposed to comment on
what is like to be Conan's
friend well how the would I
know I just walked into this studio and
they put a piece of paper underneath me
here and they say go and read this off
and comment on what it is like to be
Conan's friend I don't know I hope it's
going to be a fantastic
friendship is a give and take that's
what I hope but I mean right now I just
saw him for two minutes and we've been
gibing for a little bit here but of
course it's not the first time we've
seen each other I mean we've seen each
other many times before I've done his
show before I always had a good time and
he was in charge of promoting all my
movies that's why they went through the
roof and uh and allu so I hope that now
I I came out with a book called be
useful and I hope it does the same with
the book sell sell sell that's one of
the chapters in the book read sell sell
sell I read the book you're already much
more successful I don't even think I
need to be here no this could be this
could be Golds we should let Arnold just
keep going because this is fantastic
this is absolutely F talk too much
already no no you didn't talk fantastic
for the next 1550 minutes I'm not going
to say anything nobody nobody wants to
hear me they want to hear you no no I
want to hear you you were so funny I
listened to you when you Daniel kavi and
this guy on for the Hanson France stick
you were reading and you and you were
reading out you actually invited me but
they had the environmental conference so
I couldn't make it but that was so funny
I was laughing there's no comedy movie
to be honest with you that I have
laughed that much than just listening to
you
and exactly and exactly what was the
other guy's name Robert Smigel Robert SM
SM Smigel
smigle em
that's is making my life right now we
wrote a movie a long time ago I'm just
going to tell the viewers we wrote a
Hansen fron movie and it was uh and we
wrote you as half the movie even though
we hadn't even pitched it to you yet and
it's the most ridiculous movie in the
world and it's a musical and one of my
favorite things is we depicted your
house as being two flexed buttocks that
opened that you it
hilarious because I remember there was
one scene in there that I still remember
from the script uh where uh one of the
my cousins says um I have to go to the
bathroom and then and he says so where
do I go and I say you go right down to
the Del do
it and Del turn left and then you will
see a huge calf all split in half he
walks through the calf and they would a
sixpack I said if you see an eight pack
that's not the one the sixpack you go
goes through that like we have to make
this movie now we make this movie and
that sixpack that's you walk in and
that's where you go to the bathroom but
this is not a girly man bathroom Okay so
so I mean was all of this stuff it was
so silly and I remembered yesterday I
was talking to Robert and I was talking
and I talked to Dana a lot and I was
telling them I remembered we wrote a
scene where you were some someone passes
and it's you're very sad and you're one
of the PA bearers and with all of your
friends and then you get to the grave
and you all start doing lifts with the
coffin like we put all this foolishness
in there it was so much fun Fant IC it
was so well WR written and I hope they
do it yeah I really hope they do it
because you still do it you still money
um I will say you have it now I
mean you you bought I mean they they
they paid you almost a billion dollars
for this podast two Bill two billion two
billion two billion two billion doll it
was all Bitcoin are you mered
yeah yes I am they understand twice as
much my wife said no it needs to be two
you know I have to say I'm going to I'm
going to there's so much to talk about
but from the first time I worked at
Saturday Night Live when you came there
and you did a Hansen France sketch and I
always was a fan of your movie work you
are so funny you are hilarious
you are so naturally funny you can see
it in Pumping Iron you can see it
throughout your whole career always very
funny really funny and you came on my
show when we were out here in Los
Angeles The Late Night show
and you prepared and and that's a big
part of your book is preparation but you
kept calling our segment producer and
saying I can do better more more before
before you came on the show you had so
many great jokes you prepared more than
any comedian I think I've ever worked
with you were absolutely fantastic and
then my favorite thing is we wheeled out
a real photograph of me and boxer shorts
just boxer shorts that we took before
the show and it was life size and you
tore me apart verbally my body you went
after my body and the crowd was laughing
so hard they started stamping their feet
and the Fire Marshals were worried that
they would do structural damage it was
so I I remember that as a matter of fact
one of the things I remember was that
your producer or showrunner whatever
they call it on those those late night
shows uh told me not to throw
[Laughter]
up when they R out the big I said
wouldn't it be great if I just throw up
I said because I will find something on
his body that would be throw up
you know
so did and he said you know said that
will be too gross because it's a late
show we want to entertain people we
don't want to gross them out plus right
after you there is a food commercial we
don't want your big so your big
achievement in Show Business among many
is looking at my almost naked body and
not throwing up is that what you're
saying D that is
discipline and I talk about this and be
useful that is discipline I mean I I was
doing everything that I could trying to
kind of look at the you know uh your
deltoids uh I try not to look below the
belt and all this so I was tring doing
everything to try to stay as serious as
possible and not to throw up
congratulations but the bottom line is
you have a good body you look lean yeah
and I think it's the most important
thing to stay healthy and to stay alive
for a long time is to be lean and so
you're in the right track wrong yeah
Arnold but when you first came into the
room and you can tell me if I'm wrong I
looked right in your eyes and you looked
right in my eyes and you sized me up and
we haven't seen each other in a little
while and I saw in your eyes fear is
that correct growing up no no I saw I
saw fear I saw physical intimidation I
did not know that uh that you detected
that I I saw it I mean I I was trying to
cover
up I was trying to cover up the fear and
the intimidation uhhuh and how little I
felt compared to you careerwise
intelligence wise bodywise definition
Wise sizewise sixpack Wise everything I
mean I I say to myself maybe I can hide
my inferiority complex yeah but you
obviously saw it I saw it and not that I
smelled it it's a it's a pheromone you
can smell when fear is released into the
air I could smell it absolutely I could
smell it's sort of a smell that's what I
could yeah so to me it's more like a
vitle
smell